hey everyone persia here and we got our
hands on the halo infinite technical
preview and while it is definitely an
early build we still thought it would be
great to put together some important
things that you should know about
infinite go ahead and leave a like and
subscribe and let's hop right into it
the mini map in halo infinite works a
little bit differently than many maps of
halo's past in terms of how you are
detected by the map while the map is
always visible that doesn't necessarily
mean your enemies are going to show up
on the map just because they're in range
of course in the past crouching was a
good way to avoid detection but now you
can crouch and walk without being
detected this leaves sprinting shooting
your gun or taking damage as the
requirements needed to pop up on the
mini map so if you are used to using the
map for intel you might get snuck up on
one or two more times than expected
until you get used to this change halo
infinite also has a ping system and you
can also get points and assists for
pinging enemies correctly and helping
out the team along with that the ai
callouts are surprisingly good so if
you're not on comms then there are
definitely more options in infinite to
get some sort of communication with your
teammates without physically being on
the mic
this could just be my experience but it
felt like armor and health were slightly
redistributed usually in the past when
you broke someone's armor you knew that
they were one shot and they were close
to dead but in infinite it felt like you
had a little bit more health to give
meaning you could get yourself out of
tricky situations or have a better
chance at surviving with that in mind
making sure that the marksman weapons
were on our team were definitely a
priority as they seem to be the best
weapon at finishing cracked targets
maybe not including grenades but we'll
get to that later lens flare is in halo
infinite however i did not notice this
until the final day of the preview where
we actually got to play against real
people i guess the bots didn't have much
of a use of adsing or weren't using guns
that required them to ads so i didn't
really notice it throughout the first
few days of the preview but playing
against actual people you can definitely
tell and it even helped me spot enemies
or win vr battles so let me know down
below what you think of lens flare being
in the game
the abilities in halo infinite are
actually super interesting but first
things first if you want to pick one up
all you got to do is run or walk over it
if you have empty pockets it'll be
picked up automatically if you don't
have empty pockets then you're gonna
need to pick it up manually by holding x
the deployable shield is a lot less
annoying than i thought it was gonna be
it definitely has a long start-up time
as well so you're not going to want to
toss it in the middle of a gun fight
because you're probably going to die
before it even activates however if you
can place it down at a popular choke
point ahead of time you're always going
to have the advantage in a one-on-one
the shield itself does take damage and
chunks of it will disappear once it
takes too much damage but it's still a
great option if you're trying to get a
leg up on the competition or if you're
trying to pass a very heated choke point
with a little bit more safety the
grapple is probably my favorite ability
of all of the abilities so far it adds
some much needed variety to the vertical
movement of the game but it's not a part
of our main kit like i thought it was
going to be it's an ability that spawns
on the ground that you will have to pick
up and comes with a limited number of
uses so you also have to be strategic
with how you use it activecamo and
overshield are making their return to
halo infinite but they work a little bit
differently than how they used to they
are abilities after all which means you
will have to pick them up from their
spawn point and then you'll have to
manually apply it to get its special
effect this means you have to be smart
about picking it up and you have to be
safe about when you actually activate it
because you can die before it is fully
active and it will drop on the floor
which means your opponent can pick it up
instead
[Music]
we got to check out three of the maps
during the preview which were live fire
recharge and bizarre they were all
pretty small but exactly what you would
expect for a 4v4 slayer arena style map
which made grenades even more dangerous
and teamwork even more important but i'm
definitely here for it one of my
favorite things though about each map
was that power weapons and marksman
weapons would rotate with each and every
match so you weren't guaranteed to have
a br or commando or rockets or a sniper
but it definitely added some variety and
kind of changed how my team would
approach certain matches if a more
favorable power weapon was spawning that
match well we would favor that but if
the marksman weapons were a little bit
more in our favor then we might go that
way instead i think this is awesome and
i hope it's something that we see
consistently moving forward
now it's time to talk a little bit about
general speed and general movement per
spartan i'm not going to talk about the
grapple hook because it's not a part of
our main kit and we already talked about
how awesome it was earlier but there are
some other big things to note about the
new movement in halo infinite of course
we have our crouch and walk speed that
feels very traditional very halo like in
terms of not being very fast but we also
have the return of the sprint and we can
also slide this means that the thrust
the shoulder charge and the ground pound
for halo 5 are definitely out the window
but the sprint got a couple of buffs
which is leading me to believe that this
is going to be the main movement tool so
with sprinting in halo infinite you can
reload and you can regain your shields
while sprinting those of you familiar
with halo 5 knew that you couldn't quite
take off running until your shields were
already starting to recharge or else you
were going to be one shot forever but
now that is not the case which means if
you see some grenades coming your way
you better start running because you
might get caught in a really sticky
situation and honestly the grenades
single-handedly made me miss having a
thrust because that was my go-to tactic
in halo 5 when i saw nades coming my way
i would just thrust out of there but now
that's not so much the case which means
you have to prioritize your spread and
get a good judgment of your surroundings
much earlier than you used to
time to go ahead and talk about some of
the weapons starting with the pistol it
was definitely a polarizing feeling
using the pistol because some moments
when all of my headshots are perfect and
my aim is on point i felt i was as close
to a halo 1 pistol as i could get but if
those headshots were not accurate and i
was getting one too many body shots or
shoulder shots we easily crept into halo
2 pistol territory which is not what we
want especially when there is no dual
wield but if you got the aim to back it
up the pistol is definitely a deadly one
in
infinite perfect the br the good old
battle rifle is definitely making a
strong return to forum in infinite the
br has probably been one of my absolute
favorite weapons in the entire series
since its existence but it's super
satisfying to use an infinite which
definitely makes me one happy spartan
you can still get those perfect four
shot kills that are always glorious to
get and you also become infinitely more
dangerous at the high ground cleaning up
all those cracked targets for your team
i would highly recommend prioritizing
marksman weapons but the br above them
all if you want to be the one to clean
up those skills and bring home the dub
for your team i knew the skewer was
dangerous but i didn't truly understand
how dangerous until we got to play a few
pvp matches towards the end of the
preview any player with great aim is
gonna get easy killing sprees with the
skewers so everyone's gonna want to
watch out for this weapon because i
believe it is a one-touch kill no matter
where it hits you so a strong power
weapon for sure and if you got the aim
for it definitely make good use of it
the commando is a new marksman weapon in
halo infinite and while it is an
automatic gun i think it's much stronger
when you burst fire it because the
recoil is extremely wild it's very
unwieldy and a spray and pray method
with this gun doesn't really give you
accurate results especially considering
that there is a bit of bloom that you
have to manage now if you get used to
burst firing it it could be just as
strong as a br especially from long
distances but you definitely need a bit
more control with this weapon when the
game gives you an advice tip that tells
you you should start or end your gun
battle with a grenade i think it's safe
to say that grenades are pretty strong
and i do feel like throughout most of
the preview i probably dyed two grenades
more than i died to guns but that could
also be an ai thing because they seem to
throw the perfect grenade every single
time the perfect bounce the perfect
trajectory the perfect timing you name
it that is how these bots were throwing
the grenades when we did play some pvp
matches at the end of the preview the
grenades were a lot less accurate and i
did find myself dying to them a lot less
but they're still very powerful and the
blast radius is so strong so be careful
for those needs and keep in mind that
you also have grenades so use them
wisely especially if you see a lot of
people in an area because that's easy
doubles triples and overkills the
gravity hammer is making its return in
halo infinite and it's as deadly as ever
i initially didn't think it was that
strong because when i used it against
higher level bots they flat out
destroyed me before i ever got close
enough to actually get a swing in there
but when i played against actual players
and had some backup from my team or vice
versa fighting against someone else who
had backup from their team the hammer
became way more difficult to deal with
so that's worth keeping in mind as well
that some of these weapons are stronger
as long as you're using some teamwork
while there are many more weapons in
halo infinite the last one i'm gonna
talk about in this video is going to be
the pulse carbine the pulse carbine is a
really interesting weapon and it shoots
a three round burst of plasma bullets
these bullets kind of inherited some
halo 2 plasma pistol traits in terms
that there is a little bit of tracking
on the bullet and it only takes one
burst to break your shield it only takes
two bursts to kill you completely so
it's definitely a dangerous weapon in
the right hands but honestly i think
it's the most dangerous if you're
rolling around with a teammate who's
using a marksman weapon because then in
theory you and your teammate can go
around two-shotting every person you
come across but it also means you can
keep a marksman weapon on your secondary
and do the two shotting yourself if your
aim with the pulse carbine is on point
[Music]
alright everyone that is a wrap on this
video but that's not a wrap on halo
infinite previews because the devs have
already confirmed that more previews and
more flights are on the way for halo
infinite before launch this means you
can head over to halowaypoint.com
and you still have time to sign up for
one of those future previews by
following all the instructions for the
halo insider program don't miss out
because this game is great and you're
going to want to give it a try for
yourself and i guarantee you're going to
want to do that before lunch i hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did leave
a like let me know down below what your
favorite thing in the preview was so far
and if you want to see more halo
goodness because we're going to be doing
all of that over here on gamespot then
make sure you subscribe and hit the
notification bell thank you all so much
again for watching and we will see you
next time peace
foreign